TRYING TO GO CROSS  TO LEAVE GU
WITH HANDS LIKE ROBERTSON.
UNCONTESTED.
THERE'N FRONT.
HELLEBUYCK MAY HAVE HAD A TOUCH
ON IT.
PAVELSKI BEHIND THE
BIG HIT BY BRENDEN DILLON.
STASTNY GETS IT ON FOR BRENDEDE
BOUNCING PUCK.
IT'S PLAYED BACK AND JOE PAVELS!
HOOKING, HOOKING, TRIPPING, AND
Kevin: IT'S ALMOST --
>> Referee: MINOR KYLE CONNOR,
DIDN'T GET MUCH ON IT.
WH
YOUR BEST PENALTY KILLER
COPP WILL LEAVE IT FOR LOWRY.
DOWN FOR STASTNY, STASTNY PLAYS
IT BACK
STICKY SEAMS AND A NICE JOB.
ANDREW COPP
MORRISSEY TAKES IT OFFE'LL LEAVE
IT AT THE LINE.
EHLE
THERE'S THE TWO O HIT A BODY IN
FRONT.
HAKANPAA, GRAF THE HAT.
THAT WAS RIGHT IN MY SIG IN FORE
RIFLED OVER TOP OF THE NET,  AN
ON FOR SCHMIDT, SCHMIDT GOES
RINK-WIDE, CONNO IT IN BEHIND F
TO CONTINUE EXCEPT FOR NUMBER P.
BACK TO THE LI EYES AWAY FROM
HELLEBUYCK.
DOES HE GET A PUCK.
LOOKING FOR AS INTO THE MIX THE
AS WELL.
BACK,
HE'LL STAY WITH IT AS LIN AND
PURPOSE IN THIS LAST PRESSURED
PIERRE-LUC DUBOIS.
ON THE
JASON ROBERTSON THE SECOND
OVERTIME W